[موسيقى]
وظائف متوارثه مصطلح رمزي للكثير من
الوظائف المرتبطه بالحج والعمره في مكه
منذ عقود طويله ابراهيم نوفل حرفي تمسك
بمهنه والده وهي
حياكه كسوه الكعبه شكل من خلالها علاقه
وطيده مع الحرير والخيوط المذاهبه طوال
اربعين عام هذا المهنه بالنسبه لي انا شرف
وربي يعلم قديش بحب هذه المهنه لكن حبي في
الشغله هذه انا ما صدقت ان يكرمك ملكيه من
الله سبحانه وتعالى اني من مجرد مزاوله
المهنه هادئه على طول في المكان الى
اليدويه القديمه صار الانحراف القاعده
والاصبع زي ما انتم شايفين وكذا يعني
بيختلف الاصبع التالي شرف ربي اكرمنا فيه
حتى احنا لمسات بالنسبه لنا البصمه راحت
من يوم ما بدا تعييني في العمل وانا شغال
فيها يعني تقريبا سته
بضعوا سنوات تفصل بين هذا الحرفي الذي قضى
جل عمره في حياكه كسوه الكعبه وبين الفصل
الاخير من عمله لاقترابه من سن التقاعد ما
جعله ياخذ بيد ابنه عمر
لتعليمه هذه المهنه واكمال مسيره العائله
حتى الحب بالوظيفه دي من الوالد وقبلها
كان جدي شغال هنا
فالحب كان عن طريقه
وكملت انا الحمد لله دحين اربع سنوات
اغلى صراحه عظيمه كانت السنه اللي فاتت
كانت اول مره اطلع فوق الكعبه
في تلبيس الثوب
كان شيء شعور لا يوفر مجمع الملك عبد
العزيز لكسوه الكعبه مئات الوظائف لشباب
وشابات السعوديه
بهدف انجاز المهمه السنويه لكسوه الكعبه
التي تتجاوز تكلفتها 20 مليون ريال في كل
عام
من مكه المكرمه سلطان السلمي العربيه